un club dans chaque maison expert en
relations internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison alors dans quel contexte
intervient ce baptême sommet entre la
chine et l'union européenne dans un
contact c'est un petit peu tendu parce
que vous l'avez dit que la leur d'abord
la pandémie du corps d'un virus n'est
pas terminée la preuve c'est que ce
n'était pas une vraie réunion
diplomatique c'était une vidéoconférence
et dans cette vidéoconférence chacune
des parties s'est exprimé sur tous les
points de l'ordre du jour
successivement ce qui veut dire que à la
fin de la journée on est capable de
dresser un tableau des positions
respectives sur chacun des sujets mais
on n'a pas négocié on a négocié sur rien
du tout évidemment c'était un exercice
utile parce qu'il faut dialoguer et qu'
il n'est pas impossible que lorsque la
pandémie sera passée y est un sommet
avec physiquement les principaux chefs
d'état et de gouvernement plus les
présidents des institutions qui était
aujourd'hui devant de vendée sur les
écrans alors le deuxième la deuxième
raison de tensions c'est évidemment la
crise économique et le fait que la
pandémie et met en évidence notre
dépendance vis-à-vis de chaînes de
valeur ou une grande partie de la valeur
est créée dans des pays lointains par
exemple en chine
et puis enfin les états unis n'avaient
pas l'air très favorable à ce à ce
dialogue aujourd'hui puisque le
secrétaire d'état américain a cru utile
de dire hier que l'europe ferait bien de
se méfier car le parti communiste
chinois avait décidé de la somme est de
prendre parti et de prendre partie
naturellement pour la chine
en réalité c'est pas exactement comme ça
que les questions là que la question se
pose et je pense que l'intervention de
monsieur pompéo avait plutôt pour objet
de semer l'union européenne de prendre
le parti des états unis alors dans ce
contexte effectivement c'est une
situation assez délicate pour l'europe
autant plus qu on sait que certains
états membres sont plus sensibles aux
sirènes américaine que d'autres alors
dans ce rapport de force
l'europe peut-elle s'affirmer
écoutez je pense que oui de toute façon
l'europe est un partenaire
incontournable de la chine
elle est même son premier partenaire en
termes économiques
ça n'est pas rien et la chine considère
que l'europe est un partenaire important
elle a toujours baigné les critiques
vis-à-vis de l'europe y compris lorsque
henrik et singer disait l'europe quel
numéro de téléphone et les chinois nous
ont toujours dit mais il ya beaucoup de
numéros de téléphone en effet eh bien
nous n'avons aucun problème à faire le
tour des numéros de téléphone pour
trouver quelle est la position de
l'europe alors aujourd'hui l'europe est
à la recherche d'un accord de protection
des investissements dans les deux sens
ça fait cinquante la négociation dure
naturellement leurs voeux une
réciprocité une transparence une bonne
protection de la propriété industrielle
et on a l'impression que côté chinois on
n'avance pas beaucoup on n'a pas envie
de faire des concessions
donc c'est là dessus en effet que
devraient se concentrer la négociation à
l'avenir aujourd'hui les échanges de
marchandises entre l'union européenne et
la chine représentent 1,5 milliard
d'euros par jour par jour c'est
considérable
les intérêts des deux côtés sont
considérables et puis par ailleurs
depuis quelques mois dans cette épreuve
du coronavirus la chine par maladresse
est un peu isolé sur le plan
international et elle a besoin de
rechercher des appuis ou au moins des
neutralité bienveillante par exemple du
côté de l'europe
alors justement il ya beaucoup de sujets
qui fâchent et qui règne entre l'union
européenne et la chine
alors il y en a évidemment majeur mais
mais pas seulement entre l'union
européenne et la chine
c'est entre les pays occidentaux et la
chine et tout ce qui touche aux droits
de l'homme et notamment aujourd'hui la
situation kong
bien sûr et je crois que monsieur je
crois que
charles michel le président du conseil
européen comme madame ursula von arx yen
a souligné que bien sûr pour l'union
européenne ce serait très grave
une loi sur la sécurité nationale
viennent diminuer l'exercice des
libertés publiques
à hong kong d'ailleurs très curieusement
un diplomate chinois à bruxelles avait
cru utile hier de déclarer que si
l'union européenne étaient trop sévères
trop sélective vis-à-vis des
investissements étrangers notamment
chinois
eh bien les investisseurs iront ailleurs
mais en compte ce sera la même chose
s'il ya des lois liberticides à hong
kong est bien certain nombre
d'entreprises étrangères de banques
étrangères s'en iront ailleurs en asie
dont on voit bien beaucoup de pays
asiatiques singapour mais aussi tokyo
qui sont prêts à leur faire des
conditions très favorables alors une
dernière question cette fois sur
l'écologie est ce que la chine joue le
jeu et respecte ses engagements dans ce
domaine elles jouent le jeu dans la
mesure où dans la conférence de paris
sur le réchauffement climatique
elle a joué le jeu c'est à dire qu'elle
à la facilité la réalisation d'un accord
maintenant est une autre question de
voir comment elle se comporte
concrètement dans la diminution de co2
on constate malheureusement que la chine
a beaucoup de centrales à charbon et on
constate qu'elle continue de construire
des centrales à charbon a construit
aussi des centrales nucléaires ce qui
est mieux du point de vue d'écologie
mais elles construisent centrales à
charbon est effectivement là dessus elle
ne semble pas tout à fait respecté ses
engagements
d'une façon générale la chine respecte
le droit international
la chine soutient des organisations
multilatérales évidemment elle essaie de
les faire fonctionner un peu à sa main
on l'a vu pour l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
et on le voit maintenant lorsqu'elle
réclame un changement de la gouvernance
d'un certain nombre d'organisations
internationales pour faire plus de place
aux pays émergents la chine n'est plus
un pays émergent elle est un pays
émergés puisque c'est la deuxième
économie du monde
donc tout ça peut faire l'objet de
discussions mais je crois que
l'union européenne a sa carte à jouer et
l'union européenne dans cette affaire de
relations avec la chine est favorable à
un dialogue est naturellement sans
aucune naïveté et n'est pas n'est pas
alignée sur les états unis
merci claude blanche maison pour votre
analyse expert en relations
internationales